I was thinking about you yeah and I get
but all the guys who work on the show go
Eric's out of his [__] mind let's
give him a question what would you be
willing to do as a prank okay I want to
see where you draw the line would you
drink your own come
ooh I've drank my own hot piss before
during an interview
what wait did you hold it don't just
move away from that during an interview
was it a job interview no no
during the Eric Andre show it was a
reality show guy like a hunky Bachelor
type of guy and I just got completely
naked in front of him pissed in my
coffee mug and chugged the whole thing
off my own hot piss oh my God but uh
also when I when I um urinate I feel
like relief when I come I feel uh
embarrassment afterwards
yeah shame and embarrassment after I
come I'm in a different mental space
would you get ass implants I already
have a pretty juicy ass I'm gonna Pat
myself on the back for that yeah but
it's so funny it would be funny but I
the infection might not be so funny
would you try sneaking across the United
States Mexican border wearing a gigantic
sombrero that's a bit sure why not you
like it yeah look I just saw your eyes
light up I think you're gonna do it by
the way you can have any one of these oh
thank you you're in my writer's room
would you dip your balls in fire ants
oh that's nuts I think that's like
Stevo's jurisdiction right uh
uh depending on what it was for yeah
like if they bought another jackass
movie
I would muster up the courage to do it
you hate getting taser Johnny Knoxville
keeps tasering you on that new showing's
rough for your own show would you take a
taser to your penis
no I took a taser to my neck and quit a
show so I would say that a taser to the
penis is the only thing worse than the
neck
would you eat regurgitated stovetop
stuffing yeah you would do that so who
who vomited if I vomited it sure if
somebody else vomited it it would depend
on a new vomited would you let a guy
finger your [__] while skydiving
[Music]
fingering you he's got Lou by consider
it but yeah it's funny it's funny I mean
it is funny those formations when they
jump out of the plane and then they come
together
a finger in the [__] I think he would
do this would you stage an abortion on
the streets of Texas
[Laughter]
oh that's hardcore man yeah I guess I
have to now now you have to do it yeah
foreign